la parole est un monsieur bruno
retailleau pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mesdames messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse à à
delphine batho le 25 septembre dernier
la cour de cassation a rendu un arrêt
qui va faire date
la cour de cassation a confirmé bien sur
la culpabilité la responsabilité des
pollueurs pour la faire de verica et
elle a aussi reconnu l'existence d'une
notion juridique nouvelle le préjudice
écologique
c'est une victoire pour la vendée mon
département mais aussi pour toutes les
parties civiles prenantes à la faire
pour tous les amoureux de nature c'est
aussi je voudrais le rappeler après 13
années de combat un immense soulagement
un soulagement parce que rien n'était
fait d' avance rien n'était gagné
pour preuve c'est que l'avocat général
avait d'ailleurs requis si j'ose dire
l'annulation pure et simple de toute la
procédure
nous avons été tout près de passer
auprès si j'ose dire d'une forme de
naufrage écologique après la catastrophe
écologique aussi naufrage juridique bien
sûr il s'en est fallu de très très peu
le pire était évité
il faut désormais que nous puissions
construire le meilleur le meilleur pour
l'avenir en tirant justement pour le
futur les leçons du passé précisément en
essayant d'inscrire cette nouvelle
notion dans le droit positif je les dis
à quelques instants pour la première
fois les juges ont reconnu l'existence
du préjudice écologique c'est-à-dire un
préjudice autonome un préjudice
distingue du préjudice moral ou du
préjudice matériel
c'est fabuleux il faut donc que cette
jurisprudence puisse être inscrite dans
la loi
reconnaître et inscrire dans le code
civil justement ce préjudice écologique
c'est fondamental j'ai avec une
cinquantaine de collègues déposé au
printemps dernier une proposition de loi
dans ce sens et c'est je crois la
dernière clé de voûte qu'il faut
apporter à cet édifice sur lequel je
crois on peut tous se retrouver quel que
soit
les bancs il y a cet édifice juridique
il a été construit bien sûr par la
jurisprudence
il était construit par la loi
constitutionnelle avec la charte de
l'environnement avec la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du 8 avril 2011
il était construit aussi par la loi sur
la responsabilité de l'environnement
mais le code civil mes chers collègues à
une fragilité puisque notre code civil
je parle devant la statue de portalis et
bien notre code civil ne reconnaît un
dommage que pour autant qu'il est un
caractère personnel or or
l'environnement n'est pas un bien
personnel c'est un bien collectif c'est
la raison pour laquelle selon la belle
formule de victor hugo il faut madame la
ministre fait rentrer le droit dans la
loi ma question est simple est-ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à cette petite
révolution juridique
merci madame delphine batho ministre de
l'écologie dû développement durable
jeunes hommes et dames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bruno
retailleau l'arrêt rendu par la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation dans
la sphère de l'erika le 25 septembre
dernier à a confirmé la responsabilité
pénale de l'ensemble des acteurs de la
chaîne de transport des hydrocarbures et
au plan civil a reconnu la notion de
préjudice écologique
et je voudrais tout d'abord rendre
hommage au combat qu'ont menée les
régions les départements les communes
des 400 km de côtes françaises qui
avaient été touchées par cette pollution
qui ont tenu bon pendant onze ans pour
mener cette bataille juridique et qui
voient leur combat couronné de succès
cette décision c'est en effet un pas en
avant considérable pour la protection de
l'environnement qu'on l'application du
principe pollueur payeur avec l'as rome
reconnaissance de la responsabilité
pénale
mais aussi de la responsabilité civile
quel que soit le lieu où le sinistre
s'est produit
cette décision fera jurisprudence nous
souhaitons qu'elle fasse son entrée
pleinement dans le droit français comme
vous le savez
s'agissant du code civil c'est la garde
des sceaux christiane taubira qui à
t'engager d'ores et déjà une réforme de
grande ampleur de notre droit de la
responsabilité
c'est donc sous sa conduite que ces
réflexions se poursuivront
je sais monsieur le sénateur l'intérêt
que vous portez vous même à cette
inscription nous avons pris connaissance
de votre proposition de loi mais aussi
du colloque que vous organisez à la fin
du mois d'octobre avec un certain nombre
de juristes spécialistes du droit de
l'environnement
je suis certaine que cette initiative
d'ailleurs sera utile pour apporter des
précisions sur un certain nombre de
points qui peut ester en justice au nom
de la nature comment doit se faire la
réparation
vous avez raison de dire que le 25
septembre a été un grand jour il nous
appartient maintenant d'en tirer toutes
les conséquences et je voulais aussi
vous indiqué qu'avec frédéric cuvillier
nous sommes favorables à ce que la
france prenne lors de la prochaine
assemblée générale des nations unies une
initiative afin de proposer un protocole
additionnel à la convention de montego
bay pour construire un outil de
protection juridique international de la
haute mer qui correspondent aussi aux
mêmes exigences